this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learned to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on a link in the description in
the last few weeks we've seen defenders
of this administration go from there was
absolutely no quid pro quo there was no
conditionality there there was no quid
pro quo there - it would only be a quid
pro quo if President Trump were really
thuggish about it
grant was asked what he thought would
constitute inappropriate quid pro quo
saying hey pal you know you need to like
go after the Biden's right I'm gonna
give you any money he'd be really like
thuggish about it - quid pro quos happen
all the time and in fact they're
actually really good you just described
is a quid pro quo it is funding will not
flow unless the investigation into the
into the democratic server happened as
well we do we do that all the time with
foreign policy so what's the deal with
quid pro quos impeachable offense or
routine diplomacy tool
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer you all took Latin in high
school right everyone knows the legal
definition of quid pro quo and we can
just all go home right no you want me to
talk about why this is all relevant okay
fine
on October 22nd bill tailored the top
diplomat or chargee d'affaires
testified behind closed doors before the
House committees that are leading the
impeachment inquiry of Donald Trump
Taylor's full testimony is currently
unknown but news agencies got a hold of
Taylor's opening statement now this was
just Taylor's opening statement but what
he revealed and it basically stunned
everyone that's paying attention Taylor
you might recall was one of the
diplomats who was a party to a whatsapp
conversation with US special envoy kurt
volker and US ambassador to the EU
Gordon Sandlin Volker turned over the
transcripts of those texts to the House
committees Taylor famously texted on
September 9th as I said on the phone I
think it's crazy to withhold security
assistance for help with a political
campaign to which Gordon Sandlin replied
five hours later bill I believe you are
incorrect about president Trump's
intentions the president has been
crystal clear no quid pro quos of any
kind the president is trying to evaluate
whether Ukraine is truly going to adopt
the transparency reforms the president
Solinsky promised during his campaign I
suggest we stop the back-and-forth by
text if you still have concerns I
recommend you give Lisa Kenna or s a
call to discuss them directly thanks
Taylor was asked to testify as a witness
to the investigation into the Trump
administration's efforts to pressure
ukrainian president below to mere
zalenski into opening an investigation
into repudiated allegations of Ukraine's
interference in the 2016 US presidential
elections as well into the company
buries MA for the purpose of eliciting
or fabricating dirt on hunter Biden and
by proxy Joe Biden political candidate
for president of the United States
Taylor began his opening statement by
emphasizing the importance of the United
States relationship with Ukraine saying
our national security demands that this
relationship remains strong Tilly went
on to say more about this noting that
Ukraine now in for the last five years
has been under attack from Russia and of
the United States security assistance is
crucial to Ukraine's defence against
Russia and that withholding security
assistance would be quote crazy
and crazy is exactly what Taylor would
soon discover on the part of the Trump
administration in June Taylor delivered
a letter from President Trump to
President Solinsky congratulating him on
his election victory and inviting him to
a meeting at the Oval Office this
meeting was an apparent goal for
szalinski but in order to obtain this
goal
zalinsky had to do some things for Trump
first for example in a plan to June 28th
call with ukrainian president ambassador
Sandlin quote did not wish to include
most of the regular interagency
participants and quote said that he
wanted to make sure no one was
transcribing her monitoring as they
added president zalenski to the call
taylor noted that a short time later it
became abundantly clear to him that
quote the meeting president Solinsky
wanted was conditioned on the
investigations of burries m'a and
alleged the ukrainian interference in
the 2016 US elections and that this
quote irregular policy channel was
guided by Rudy Giuliani on July 18th
Taylor learned from an individual at the
Office of Management and Budget the OMB
that there was a hold on security
assistance to Ukraine this individual
could not explain why there was a hold
but Taylor had a pretty good idea when
Taylor inquired further the individual
told him that her boss had quote
instructed her not to approve any
additional spending of security
assistance for Ukraine until further
notice this unidentified individual also
relayed that the directive for the hold
had come directly from President Trump
through Mick Mulvaney to the OMB z--
chief of staff this is very very bad and
we'll talk about in a moment this is
strong evidence for a quid pro quo in
his statement Taylor went on to
emphasize how important US aid to
Ukraine was and how many more lives
could be lost if the hold remained he
also noted that the Secretary of Defense
Secretary of State the CIA director and
the national security adviser all tried
to sit down with President Trump and
convince him to release the hold this
sit down however was quote hard to
schedule what President Trump wanted
Taylor discovered was for zalenski to
quote say that he will help the
investigation and address any specific
personnel issues if there are any
Trump's administration wanted zalenski
to publicly announce his participation
in this investigation and they even
tried to give zalenski a scrip
of what to say to trump suggesting that
he announced the quote I will leave no
stone unturned with regard to quote
investigations all the while making it
look like the US was uninvolved
zelinsky's response according to Taylor
to all of this was that he did not want
to quote be used as a pawn in a u.s.
re-election scheme this testimony paints
a picture of the Trump administration's
motivations by withholding US aid they
hope to get Solinsky to announce his
investigation into Joe Biden's son in
the hopes that it would bolster trumps
reelection campaign at this point the
clock was ticking with regard to
security assistance to Ukraine because
of the way the u.s. budget works if the
funds weren't released by the end of
September they would essentially expire
and disappear not to mention the actual
Ukrainians whose lives were at stake in
the last five years
13,000 Ukrainians have been killed by
Russian soldiers and potentially dozens
of ukrainian civilians had been killed
by russia during this time period taylor
was worried especially because quote if
the White House did not lift the hold
prior to the end of the fiscal year
September 30th the funds would expire
and Ukraine would receive nothing as the
wait went on ambassador Sandlin
explicitly stated that quote the
Security Assistance money would not come
until present Solinsky committed to
pursue the buries m'a investigation
Taylor's fears were confirmed this was
the first time that he had heard that
security assistance not just a White
House oval office meeting was
conditioned on zalenski committing to
investigating buries m'j the bottom line
is that taylor testified that one there
was in fact a quid pro quo the White
House conditioned the release of four
hundred million dollars of military aid
on Ukraine's statement that they were
opening investigation into buries m'a
number two the order to withhold aid
came from the President himself number
three this was never about corruption it
was about getting dirt on Joe Biden and
his son and number four the White House
tried to hide their involvement by
scripting Ukraine's announcement and
pretending that the investigations had
been Ukraine's idea all along it's of
course always important to take a step
back and look at the various players
everyone has bias that is an important
to recognize when you have two
conflicting accounts Taylor is a career
diplomat who served in both Republican
and Democratic administrations so could
he be too close to Ukraine of course
interestingly
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
specifically asked Taylor to essentially
come out of retirement to help with the
situation
Taylor was essentially president Trump's
picked to run diplomacy with Ukraine
Taylor acknowledge his own bias in
stating that he wanted the u.s. to
support Ukraine and conditioned his
coming out of retirement on that very
fact on the other side of the coin there
is Gordon Sandlin who is a hotel yay who
donated million dollars to Trump's
inauguration allegedly when Gordon
sunland's testified behind closed doors
he did not recall most of what Bill
Taylor testified to although he doesn't
appear to outright contradict anything
that Bill Taylor actually said Taylor
allegedly took contemporaneous notes
throughout the affair in addition to
bill Taylor's testimony
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh an
army officer assigned to the National
Security Council also testified recently
he was one of the members of the NSC
that listened to the infamous July 25th
call from the Situation Room according
to his opening statement VIN Minh
largely confirmed the account of the
whistleblower and the readout that has
already been made public and which I
covered in an earlier video VIN Minh
testified in his opening statement that
he was quote concerned by the call
stating I did not think it was proper to
demand that a foreign government
investigate a u.s. citizen and I was
worried about the implications for the
u.s. government support of Ukraine I
realized that if Ukraine pursued an
investigation into the Biden's and
burries m'a it would likely be
interpreted as a partisan play which
would undoubtedly result in Ukraine
losing the bipartisan support it had
thus far maintained this would all
undermine US national security following
the call I again reported my concerns to
the NSA's lead counsel The New York
Times is also reporting that VIN Minh
stated in his deposition which lasted 10
and a half hours and that's quite a long
time that he requested several changes
to the wording of the readout of the
call but that those changes were
rejected by the White House for unknown
reasons
vend Minh also testified about an
earlier July tenth call with all
examiner donna luke the secretary of the
national security defense counsel for
ukraine and national security advisor
bolton ambassadors Volcker and sunland
and energy secretary Rick Perry binman
testified that during this July tenth
call the meeting proceeded well until
Ukrainians broached the subject of a
meeting between the two presidents
ambassador Sandlin started to speak
about delivering specific investigation
in order to secure the meeting with the
president at which time ambassador
Bolton cut the meeting short following
this meeting there was a scheduled
debriefing during which ambassador
Sandlin emphasized the importance that
Ukraine deliver the investigations into
the 2016 election the Biden's and
burries m'a I stated to ambassador
Sandlin that his statements were
inappropriate that the request to
investigate Biden and his son had
nothing to do with national security and
that such investigations were not
something the NSC was going to get
involved in or push dr. hill then
entered the room and asserted to
ambassador Sandlin that his statements
were inappropriate following the
debriefing meeting I reported my
concerns to the NSCs lead counsel dr.
hill also reported the incident to the
NSA's lead counsel so in general
Lieutenant Colonel VIN moons testimony
backs up bill tailors and refutes the
testimony of ambassador Gordon song land
additionally there have been attacks
from the right against
lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh for his
status as a Ukrainian immigrant and
allegations of dual loyalty despite the
fact that he's the US citizen and
longtime member of the army it's not
clear that these attacks or criticisms
are based on anything more than
speculation so that brings us to the
quid pro quo now of course in the famous
online text Sandlin relayed that the
president has been crystal clear that no
quid pro quos of any kind but just
because they claim that doesn't
necessarily mean that it wasn't a quid
pro quo arrangement as Taylor himself
said in response to this contention
quote president Trump did insist that
President Zaleski go to a microphone and
say he is opening investigations of
verismo and 2016 election interference
and that presidents eleska should want
to do this himself
quid pro quo translates literally to
this for that it is a type of exchange
where someone on one side gives a thing
of value to someone else and expect
something in return from that person
whether a quid pro quo is illegal and
illicit depends on the context if I give
you $5.00 and you give me a book that's
a quid pro quo and there's nothing wrong
with that but things take a turn when
you're talking about government
officials using the power of their
office to extract a personal benefit
oftentimes a quid pro quo emerges in a
governmental setting when a government
official receives something of personal
value
and then abuses his or her official
power to give something in return to
that specific constituent who gave some
personal benefit to that government
official you can imagine a government
contractor who gives a fancy new sports
car to a government official who then
steers a valuable governmental contract
to that contractor that is a classic
quid pro quo illegal quid pro quo
arrangements also tend to pop up in a
workplace setting a quid pro quo would
exist where an employer demands sexual
favors in return for an employee keeping
their job so it depends on the context
Mick Mulvaney has recently been
emphasizing that especially in foreign
policy settings quid pro quo
arrangements happen all the time that's
just the nature of foreign policy we do
that all the time with foreign policy
I'll help you do this if you help me do
that everyone is happy and secure for
example throughout the history of the
United States we have used our own aid
or assistance as leverage for achieving
things such as democracy abroad an end
to corruption and even physical access
to important geographical areas for
example President Jimmy Carter provided
Egypt with aid in exchange for Egypt
making peace with Israel President Bush
even demanded that countries provide
free speech and freedom of assembly
before receiving certain US aid however
while this may be true quid pro quos
that involve a concerted self-interest
for a particular politician do not
happen all the time in foreign policy
quite frankly they really don't happen
at all in fact it was such a stunning
admission by Mick Mulvaney to admit that
this was a quid pro quo on behalf of the
Trump administration ostensibly for
president Trump that it elicited an
almost immediate walk back from Mulvaney
and the rest of the administration this
arrangement between the Trump
administration and President zalenski of
Ukraine falls into the problematic
category of quid pro quos for a couple
of reasons first of all such an
arrangement is probably highly illegal
and may be sufficient to prove the
crimes of bribery and election
interference well would be admittedly
difficult to indict and convict a
president of these crimes for reasons
that we've already talked about on this
channel in order to establish a prima
facie case for bribery under 18 USC 201
one would have to prove that a public
official in this case president Trump
directly or indirectly corruptly
demanded anything of value personally
in this case bolstering his re-election
campaign in return for being influenced
in the performance of any official act
in this case releasing money that
Congress in the Pentagon had already
appropriated for Ukraine or you can take
for example 51 USC three zero one two
one which states that it shall be
unlawful for a foreign national directly
or indirectly to make a contribution or
donation of money or other thing of
value or to make an express or implied
promise to make a contribution or
donation in connection with a federal
state or local election in this case one
would argue that the thing of value is
investigating a political rival which
obviously the Trump administration would
try to lord over the head of Joe Biden
as he tries to secure the Democratic
nomination for potentially running for
president of United States in 2020
additionally an apart from whether any
of these acts fit the neat statutory
definitions of these crimes and overcome
the constitutional issues in terms of in
dining a sitting president this
arrangement is problematic because it
essentially means that the President of
the United States is subverting the
national interest for his own personal
interest in other words he's putting
himself above the entire country now no
one argues that hunter Biden's status as
a board member of Purisima doesn't smack
of nepotism
but strong-arming a sovereign nation
into investigating a conspiracy theory
about ukrainian computer servers and
shinning up a defunct investigation into
buries m'a appears to serve president
Trump only and not US national interest
it appears motivated primarily if not
solely to help President Trump get
reelected and not to help America Rudy
Giuliani tweets the quiet part out loud
when he tweeted with all the fake news
let me make it clear that everything I
did was to discover evidence to defend
my client against false charges
Dems would be horrified by the attacks
on me if my client was a terrorist but
they don't believe real Donald Trump has
rights the problem here is that at the
request of the president Rudy Giuliani
was running his own shadow foreign
policy operation and he's admitting that
in this context he wasn't acting on
behalf of America but acting on behalf
of his client
Donald Trump in trying to get dirt
against a political rival if this had
been in America's interest President
Trump would have used the usual
diplomatic channels gone through the
mutual legal assistance treaty and
avoided using an entirely separate
clandestine shadow foreign policy team
led by Rudy Giuliani this kind of
arrangement pressuring Ukraine to do
something to benefit president Trump
personally in exchange for four hundred
million dollars in US aid and assistance
is what appears to be an abuse of power
and an attempt to use one's official
capacity as president for personal gain
now some including former acting
Attorney General Matthew Whitaker have
argued that an abuse of power is not a
crime what evidence of a crime you have
I mean the Constitution you know sort of
abuse of power is not a crime the
Constitution is very clear that this has
to be some pretty egregious behavior
however such an abuse of power is a
crucial inquiry as far as impeachment is
concerned that's because impeachment was
designed to dismantle this kind of abuse
of power ironically Bill Taylor came out
of retirement at the request of Mike
Pompeo to help Ukraine now he'll
probably want to go back into retirement
and now that he has more time on his
hands maybe he'll finally listened to
his grandkids and join Instagram after
taking Brandon Wolfe falls class
instagram-worthy photography shoot edit
and share or maybe he will finally
tackle all those chores around the house
his wife asked him to do like
redesigning his family room he could
really use Emily Henderson's Skillshare
class style your space creative tips and
techniques for interior design
Skillshare is an online learning
community that has tens of thousands of
classes on everything like music design
lifestyle and technology it's great for
former top diplomats who suddenly find
themselves with a lot more time on their
hands a yearly membership is less than
$10 per month but legal eagles will get
two free months of Skillshare when you
click on the link below plus it really
helps out this channel the free premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
must know topics so you can prove your
skills and learn new things all free for
two months so improve yourself now while
you're waiting to give your own
congressional testimony before the house
impeachment inquiry do you agree with my
analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out my other real law
reviews over here where I talk about the
whistleblower hearsay objections to the
impeachment
in tons of other breaking news and as
always I will see you in court